(mysterious music)
- So today, we're gonna,
we're a little bit behind chronologically.
I need to spend some more
time on the 1940s and 1950s,
which is what we're gonna do today.
And then the next lecture, we'll catch up
to Khrushchev and Brezhnev.
What we need to make sure we understand
because it's really important
for everything that comes later
is the transition out of the war.
And the reason why this is so important
is that the Second World War,
I mean in addition to the ways
that it's so to speak,
objectively important,
the millions of deaths,
the territorial changes,
the movements of populations,
it's also ideating,
ideologically very important.
The Second World War is a
kind of new starting point
for the legitimation of the Soviet Union,
and it's also a starting
point for many other stories
of many other nations about who they are.
The United States is far
away from the conflict.
The United States lost
relatively few people,
it entered the conflict very late.
But nevertheless,
the Second World War is very important
for American self-formation.
The closer you get to the conflict,
the more true this is,
the state of Israel, Germany,
Ukraine, Belarus, Russia,
contemporary countries,
run their stories of themselves
through the Second World War.
And in the case of the Ukraine
and other countries we're working on,
it's through the Second World War,
but then also through
a kind of Soviet myth
of the Second World War.
So we have to make sure
that we get the Second World War right
in order for us to watch how
that political memory forms
and then we'll have some way
to evaluate what's going on today.
So in the background of everything
I'm doing today is 2022,
and the way we're thinking about nations
and the war in 2022,
I'm gonna be talking
about the '40's and '50's,
but occasionally I'm going
to lurch over and remind you
to look for a connection.
Okay so was anybody else in
New York over the weekend?
I was in, see, oh yeah,
I was hoping I was gonna
be the coolest one in class
for once, all right.
So I was in New York over the weekend
and I saw the new Tom Stoppard play.
That's cool, right, that's cool?
Okay, good, I'm reassured.
The new Tom Stoppard play
is very, it's for him,
it's very straightforward,
it's very historicist,
it's about a family, an Austrian Jewish,
partly Jewish Austrian family
in the late 19th century
into the second half of the 20th century
and I don't want to spoil the end,
but you know, in the end,
most of them die at Auschwitz.
The problem with that is
that most Austrian Jews
didn't die at Auschwitz,
like that's an easy way to close a play
because everyone thinks
the Holocaust is Auschwitz
and Auschwitz is the Holocaust.
And so naturally,
if you're trying to bring it
all to a tragic conclusion,
which he does very powerfully,
having the children die at
Auschwitz is the way to do that.
The problem though historically
is that most Austrian
Jews died in Belarus.
And once you know that odd little fact,
then you are reminded that the
Second World War took place
on a territory.
And you might move from
there to remembering
that the second world
war happened as a result
of German imperialism towards the East.
So the actual geography of the Holocaust
reminds you that the Germans
were in a certain place,
they were trying to
conquer a certain place,
and that the killing began
and actually continued
in all sorts of places,
which we often forget,
like Minsk, like Riga.
Auschwitz of course, was
a center of the Holocaust,
around a million Jews were killed there,
more than a million
people were killed there.
But this little artifact of our culture
where everything leads to Auschwitz
has the consequence of making this think
that everything in some
way leads to nowhere
because Auschwitz is not a place
where you have to know where
it is on the map, right?
I mean, maybe you do,
maybe you've been there,
but it functions as a kind of nowhere,
as a kind of zero point,
as a kind of kind of black
hole where everything ends.
Right, literature ends,
philosophy ends, thought ends.
Right, Primo Levi says
"Here there is no why".
But actually, the Holocaust
took place in a place,
and Auschwitz is also a place,
and if this were a different class,
we would spend more time
on what kind of a place Auschwitz was.
But here, what I'm trying,
the point I'm trying to get across
is how deep in our culture it goes
that Eastern Europe isn't really a place,
that these territories
don't really matter.
And that in extremists,
we will look away from
the actual territories.
And in extremists, we'll
find this reference point,
which is familiar,
but which gets us not looking at Ukraine
or the Baltic states or Belarus or Poland
or western Russia,
which is where the Holocaust
was actually centered.
The reason I'm dwelling on this
is that whether or not you
think about the territories
is going to affect
how you think about
responsibility for the war.
And if we think about the lecture,
so if you think about
the lecture last time
about the German factor, right,
if you're a German
and you don't know
that there was a German
factor in Ukrainian history,
you're not gonna be thinking
about the German factor, right?
If your view of the war
doesn't have territory in it,
then it also doesn't have
most of the peoples in it
and your recollection is going
to have those peoples in it,
and you're not going to be concerned
about how you come to
terms with those things.
So part of colonialism is
forgetting about colonialism,
right, that's part of the trick.
Part of being a colonialist,
a good colonialist forgets
about colonialism, right,
and has various devices of doing so.
The European Union for all
of its undoubted virtues
is a project of forgetting
about colonialism.
They're not the only people,
there are other ways to do it,
but what the European Union
does is it tells a story
about how the Europeans
fought the Second World War,
they realized war was a very bad thing,
and therefore they chose peace,
and unlike the Americans,
they stopped fighting wars.
Yes, exactly, exclamation point,
but that's not true, that's not true.
What happened instead
is that Europeans kept
fighting wars until,
this is much more banal,
until they lost them,
which admittedly is like,
that doesn't really work
as the beginning of
the speech in Brussels,
you know, it doesn't really work
as educational curriculum in
Europe but that's the truth.
The Germans lost the Second World War,
which is a colonial war.
The French lost in Southeast Asia,
they lost in North Africa.
The Portuguese and the Spanish
couldn't hold out in Africa
any longer, right, and so on and so forth.
At which point, they then joined together
to this European integration process,
at which point they
started telling the story
about how Europeans are
very peaceful people,
and we've always been very peaceful,
and we integrate and look at us,
and then look at the
Americans, they're bad, right?
That's actually the
European national anthem.
It's set to a tune by Beethoven
but those are the words.
If you don't know German,
that's actually what
they're singing, okay.
Don't email me about that.
Okay.
All right.
It's "Ode to Joy" of course, in fact.
It's actually "Ode to Joy",
the words are by Schiller.
But the point is that,
there's a serious point here,
which is that although
the European Union is,
we'll talk more about this,
but a theme of this class
is the world of empire
and what you do after empire, right?
And the European Union
is an answer to what to do after empire.
You go back to Europe
and you don't talk about empire very much
and you cooperate with one another,
which has many good sides.
But what it means is that
you don't talk about empire.
The Dutch don't talk so
much about Indonesia, right?
And the Germans do talk
about the Holocaust,
one has to give them credit for that,
they absolutely do talk
about the Holocaust,
and in that sense, they do
better than everybody else,
but what they don't talk
about is imperial territory.
They don't really talk about
empire or colonization,
which really is the operative framework
for what they were doing in Ukraine.
And so the tricky part of
all this is that if you do,
if you do memory of the Holocaust,
but without territory and
without the other people,
you lose sight of the fact
that you yourself were the colonizer.
And since you lose sight of the fact
that you yourself were the colonizer,
you tend to forget the things
that colonization involves,
like putting local people into
awkward, difficult positions.
Right, so you don't colonize by yourself,
there are always more local people
involved than there are
colonizers involved,
there have to be just mathematically.
And when you're the colonizer,
one of the things that you're doing
is you are creating structures
that local people will be taking part in.
And later on when you
remember you're the colonizer,
that's one of the things
that you think about, right?
So if you're thinking
about the European
colonization of North America,
you don't just think
about what the Europeans
did to the native
peoples of North America,
you think about how they
turned them against each other
and how they used one
tribe against each other
and so on and so forth.
That's part of the story, right?
Likewise, when Germany
invades Eastern Europe
and rallies collaborators, yes,
the nation should come to terms
with their history of collaboration
in so far as it exists,
but the Germans also should recognize
that this is part of their history, right,
the history of colonization.
Now why am I talking about all this?
I'm talking about all this
because in the 21st century,
we have a kind of problem,
which this lecture
is going to lead us to understand I hope,
which is that before this
war in 2022 broke out,
Ukraine didn't really exist
as a subject in Germany.
Ukrainians didn't really
exist as a full-fledged people
from the German point of view.
Insofar as they existed,
they very often existed
as a trigger for luxury,
like you do this better,
you do that better,
you do the other thing better.
You learn your lesson
from the Second World War,
the way that we learned our lesson
from the Second World War.
But that analogy doesn't make sense
because the Germans
were the colonizer in
the Second World War,
and they colonized Ukraine, right?
So you can't lecture, you
know, you can't lecture,
as an American, you can't
lecture the Osage about this.
You have to sort of realize
what you did to the Osage.
And the Germans weren't there yet.
And that had the odd consequence
that up until 2022,
the Germans and the Russians
were able to find a kind of
common ground about Ukraine
along the lines of they
don't really exist.
They're sort of, they're
kind of a problem for us,
they're sort of complicated,
they don't really exist.
And there was a divvying up of roles
about the Second World War,
which I hope we'll be able
to challenge after this class
where Germany and Russia up to 2022,
this is now all being reconsidered,
but up to 2022,
the Germans and the Russians
had this kind of nice deal
where they divided the
good things about the war.
What the German said was,
we get the good thing
of having learned all
about it and apologized.
And the Russians said,
we get the good thing of
having been the victims
and the victors, right,
which is a nice position to be in.
And everybody else kind of
complicates the story, right?
And so from from those positions,
you know, you can see eye to eye
like it's too bad that we invaded you
but it's a good thing you won and so on
and everyone else in the
middle kind of gets forgotten,
all those territories,
those awkward territories get forgotten.
Together, we can reproduce
stereotypes about Ukraine,
together, we can talk
about how it's all corrupt.
Together, we can talk
about how they don't
really have a language,
you know, and so on.
We can do all these things
that are quite colonial and not notice it.
together. We can build a pipeline.
Together, we can become
economically dependent upon you.
All of this goes back
to the Second World War.
All of it goes back to
the German colonization,
which I talked about last time.
This time, we're going to be talking about
the way that the Soviet Union
handled the Second World War.
Without this knowledge,
we can't get to where we are now,
the '70's, '80's, '90's,
21st century and 2022.
Okay, so I tried to make
clear the memory stakes.
Now let me talk about some of the,
some of the actual events.
What we're gonna do today is
we're gonna get through the war
into the end of Stalin
so you can see how this all gets set up.
And the basic story is
going to be something like
the war is processed as
victimhood and victory,
but for Russians more than
for other people, right?
Once you know that that process
begins and begins in 1945,
the rest of it step by step to
Putin becomes less confusing.
And the way that the
Russians and the Germans
are going to come to this
weird common understanding
about the war also becomes less confusing.
Okay so history.
I'm gonna take what seems
like a big lateral step now
and talk about,
and talk about the Organization
of Ukrainian Nationalists
and the ethnic cleansing of Poles
during the Second World War.
How is this not a big lateral step?
It's not a big lateral step because
in order to understand
the Organization of Ukrainian Nationalists
and its ethnic cleansing
of Poles during the war,
you have to understand the war,
and you have to understand
Soviet and German policies
during the war.
So, I mean to be very clear,
if you're a Ukrainian and
you are identifying yourself
with this tradition
of the Organization of
Ukrainian Nationalists,
then there are things
that you need to know
and things you have to consider
and they will be in this lecture.
But analytically,
if we're gonna understand
where it came from,
we have to know what Soviet policy was
and what German policy was
because there's a sort of mystery here.
I mentioned
the Organization of Ukrainian
Nationalists earlier
as a minor, mostly
imprisoned terrorist group
in Interwar Poland, right?
If it hadn't been for
the Second World War,
we probably wouldn't remember them,
with all due respect, at all.
They weren't that many people.
They didn't matter that much in Poland
except for the few assassinations,
and they didn't really
matter anywhere else.
I'm definitely getting email about that,
but that's the truth, right?
The Second World War changed
the setup dramatically.
How so?
Well inside Poland, by the '30's,
there was a consensus among
Ukrainian political life
to accept the Polish state.
That was hard,
it was disappointing that
there was no Ukrainian state.
But by the second half of the 1930s,
people generally understood
that the Soviet Union was much worse,
that Poland was threatened,
and therefore we accept the
legality of the Polish state,
we try to function within it.
That position, which was the
majority Ukrainian position
by the second half of the
1930s, becomes impossible
when?
- [Student] When Poland ceases to exist.
- Poland ceases to exist,
100% exactly right.
I mean it seems like such an easy point,
but the difference between a
state existing and not existing
is traumatic for all of the citizens,
but especially for the
national minorities.
If this were a class on the Holocaust,
I would now be spending a
lot more time on that point
with respect to the Jews.
Because membership in a
state which treats you poorly
is still very much different
than non-membership in any state,
right, that's the
argument in "Black Earth".
For the Ukrainians, it suddenly means
there's no one to cooperate with
that was a legitimate state a day before.
The democratic parties,
like UNDO, which I mentioned
last time, they melt away,
the left wing parties or the
radical left wing parties,
the communists and the
cryptocommunist parties,
they cooperate with the Soviets
in what becomes Western Ukraine.
And as we saw last time
or the time before,
they become disappointed.
What's left after that
is the extreme right.
The Organization of
Ukrainian Nationalists,
the people who have experience,
who have a coherent ideology
of national superiority and discipline,
who have practice being underground,
unlike everybody else
except the communists,
and the communists have
now come above ground
and been disappointed,
they have practice being underground.
They are willing to do
things like use violence,
which the other parties weren't
necessarily willing to do.
So they're advantaged in that way,
if that's the word, by 1939.
They are also advantaged,
or they're also transformed
by the war itself.
So by the time the Germans
invade the Soviet Union,
the Soviets are just starting to find
and deport the Ukrainian Nationalists.
Germany invades the Soviet Union,
and the Ukrainian Nationalists
declare a Ukrainian state.
That was not the German's
idea at all, right?
So you now know enough
about the German understanding of Ukraine
to understand that it didn't
require the Ukrainians
to found a state.
On the contrary,
Ukraine was meant to be
colonized by Germany.
If there were some Ukrainians
who would be useful in that,
all the better, but the
idea was to create a colony.
So in early July, 1941,
sorry late June, 1941,
the Organization of Ukrainian Nationalists
decides to declare a state.
This effort fails dramatically
because the Germans don't support it.
Okay, this is a crucial point here, right?
The Germans are all in favor
of Ukrainian non-political collaboration,
but they have no interest
in Ukrainian political collaboration.
So the people who declare independence
generally get sent to camps.
Roughly four-fifths of the leaders
of the Ukrainian Nationalists
now go to German camps or prisons,
including Stepan Bandera,
who is the one who is
most often mentioned.
So Bandera spent the Second World War,
or most of the second world
war in Bergbauernhilfe
in a German camp.
He wrote letters, it's
true, but he had very,
I mean he's the figure that
the Russians now fixate on,
but he had very little to do
directly with anything
that happened in the war,
because he was in a German camp.
But the reason this is
relevant is that the,
what was already a very
radical organization
was stripped of its top leadership.
And very, no offense,
very young people were suddenly in charge,
people who had, just for the
record, that got one smile,
okay, very young people
were suddenly in charge.
And this meant that
was what was already a
kind of unpredictable,
violent organization becomes more so.
What's worse, just before this happened,
the Organization of Ukrainian Nationalists
had split into two fractions
associated with these two
leaders, Melnyk and Bandera,
and those two fractions set
about killing one another,
thereby further disrupting
the leadership structure
of the organization
and making it more likely
that it would carry out
other kinds of disruptive acts.
Many of these people
do in fact collaborate with the Germans.
We're talking about a few thousand people
in a nation of tens of millions,
but many of them do in fact
collaborate with the Germans,
some of them are in the
German police force.
And this too,
so this is where my
earlier point comes in,
none of that could have happened
without the German invasion.
Right so these men, a
few thousand of them,
get a specific form of training
as a result of the war.
Oh and it's more
interesting than I just said
because I know this is the hard part,
you see, it already messed me up,
when Poland is broken,
the power that comes into Eastern Poland
is the Soviet Union.
And a lot of young men then join,
a lot of young Ukrainian men
then join the Soviet militia.
And those deportations of Poles,
which I mentioned earlier
and will mention again,
many times, the local militia
men who carried them out
were of Ukrainian nationality.
Here comes the part of the
story that nobody likes,
but which is, there are many
parts that nobody likes,
but this part particularly nobody likes.
When the Soviets are
driven out by the Germans
in summer 1941,
a lot of those Soviet militia
men of Ukrainian nationality
then joined the Germans.
Now from a human perspective,
this is totally normal.
If you're a young man who'd
been making his living
as a kind of quasi police
officer on the countryside
and one power goes away
and the other power comes,
and they also are in need of a job
doing basically the same thing,
you know, carrying a baton
and driving people into
deportation columns,
different people to be sure,
you're probably gonna take the same job,
right, a lot of it is as banal is that.
But in our world of ideology
where we think like,
oh, they're Stalinists and they're Nazis,
and they're this nation
and they're that nation
and that determines everything they do,
it's very hard to get our minds around
the kind of basic social
fact of double collaboration
and the basic human realities,
which led a lot of people
to behave in that way.
But what this means is
that a lot of these men
who just had experience
putting Poles and other
people onto deportation trains
are now serving as
German auxiliary police,
mostly enforcing the German idea of law
on their fellow Ukrainians,
but among other things, and
this is very significant,
taking part in the policy
of the mass murder of Jews,
which we know as the Holocaust.
So as always in a colonial situation,
there are relatively few
people from the colonial power.
About 1,400 Germans
are directly involved in rounding up Jews.
About 12,000 locals are
responsible for the murder
of about 200,000 Jews in Western Ukraine.
I'm talking about Western Ukraine
because that's where
the nationalists were.
The people who were
the locals, by the way,
they were Ukrainians, but
they weren't only Ukrainians.
There were also Poles,
there were other people,
but they were predominantly Ukrainians
in this part of the world.
And then all of these Jews were murdered,
usually by Germans,
but certainly with the increasing help,
especially after 1942
of locals by bullets at close range.
So that is the education
that several thousand young men got.
They wouldn't have gotten this
education in interwar Poland.
They certainly wouldn't have gotten it
in an independent Ukraine.
They got it as a result of a
joint German Soviet invasion
and then as a result of a
German invasion of the territory
which the Soviets just took.
These men were then the ones
who were directly involved
in ethnic cleansing of Poles
in 1943.
The conjuncture was that the
Germans are being driven out,
it looks like the Soviets are coming.
The Soviets, okay here comes
another part of the story,
which nobody likes,
but which is absolutely
true and important,
the Soviets are recruiting people
for their own partisan movement.
They are not picky at all about
who those people are, right?
So plenty of German collaborators
go right into the Soviet
partisan movement.
The Soviets are recruiting them.
They're trying to recruit German policemen
to the Soviet partisans.
And one attempt to try to,
one attempt to try to
recruit them negatively
by a provocation ends up with
a lot of Ukrainian policemen,
German policemen of Ukrainian nationality
going over to what turns out to be
a Ukrainian partisan movement.
And that Ukrainian partisan movement,
the UPA on your sheet,
these are the people
who carry out the ethnic
cleansing of Poles
in the summer of 1943, tens of thousands.
The Poles respond,
they kill a fair number of Ukrainians too,
especially in Galicia.
And this end, and so you
can imagine this scene now,
by 1944 when the Red Army appears,
the Red Army appears on territories
where Ukrainians and Poles
are busily killing one,
killing one another, okay so.
Going back to where we are now, it is,
it's just important to
remember that these crimes,
which have to be known about,
this history which has to be known
whether you're Ukrainian or not,
if you're German,
what you have to know about them
is that they would never have
happened without you, right?
They would never have
happened without you.
Without the German colonization policy,
none of this would have happened.
The men who take part in all of this,
if you're Ukrainian and you
identify with Ukrainians,
then you think about this
and you think about
responsibility, I think.
But if you're a German, you think,
huh, it looks like we
created the conditions
in which something like
this could happen, right?
That is part of what
doing colonial history
or doing imperial history
reflectively involves.
Okay and then yeah.
One more reflection about Ukraine.
The OUN, the Organization
of Ukrainian Nationalists,
this small group which
became important briefly
during the Second World War and after,
it had a very specific notion
of what the Ukrainian nation was.
It was a hierarchical notion
with a leader who would
have absolute power,
or a small group of men who
would have absolute power.
The power would be exercised vertically.
The Ukrainian ethnos
was thought to be a kind of super group,
super, the ubermenschen
among all the other people's.
That and more.
I'm just gonna note that
that is very different
than the notion of Ukrainian nationality
which is prevailing now, right?
And it's also very different,
I'll note something else,
they lost, the UPA lost,
and the Ukrainian state as
it's currently configured,
which is on a very different basis
with a Jewish democratically
elected president
and a very horizontally
organized civil society,
that Ukrainian setup is not
only the one that we have,
but it's the one which is winning a war.
Okay, I'm just gonna close with that
and people can reflect on it
'cause we really have to get
to where we're going now,
which is Soviet ethnic cleansing.
So the Soviets,
and this is another irony
of the war or not irony,
the Soviets pick up in many
ways where the Germans,
or locally in West Ukraine,
where the Ukrainian
Nationalists leave off.
The Soviets ethnically cleanse
with ferocity and
determination and with purpose
at the end of the Second World War.
You'll remember that in the '30's,
the Soviets were pioneers
of what we now call ethnic cleansing
with the national actions of 1937 and '38,
directed against notably
Poles, Latvians, Koreans.
During the Second World War, '40, '41,
there were these four major deportations
from territories taken from Poland.
When the Germans invaded,
Stalin deported ethnic Germans
for the first time on mass
with such organization and such skill
that the Germans themselves were envious,
which by the way is a theme.
The Soviets had a deportation apparatus,
which was very precise, which
the Germans never actually,
never actually had.
And in 1940, you can see
the German policemen,
who at that time were in a form
of cooperation with the Soviets
and observing what they were doing,
in their correspondence back to Berlin,
they would express this envy.
Like we don't have an apparatus like this,
we couldn't do this kind of thing
the way that the Soviets are doing.
But that's just to remind you
that ethnic cleansing
as a operational habit
was already present.
When the Soviets take back
territory in '43, '44,
they take entire national groups
and deport them deep
into the Soviet depths.
I don't have time to go
into all the examples now,
but it's peoples of the caucuses
and then it's peoples of Crimea.
And for the purposes of
a class about Ukraine,
the Crimean Tatars are the
most important example.
The Crimean Tatars were of
course, as we would say now,
the indigenous people of
the Crimean Peninsula.
As you'll remember from
not so many weeks ago,
the Crimean Khanate had
been a state for 400 years
before the Russian Empire
came in the late 18th century.
In the late 18th century,
there were essentially no Russians
in what was called New Russia,
but the Crimean Tatars were
about 100% of the population
of the Crimean Peninsula.
By spring of 1944, that was zero.
That was zero because in March of 1944,
180,014 people identified
as Crimean Tatars,
men, women and children,
were all forcibly deported,
most of them to Uzbekistan
on the logic that the
entire Crimean Tatar people
had collaborated with not to Germany.
And this logic, this totalizing logic
was applied also to Crimean Tatars
who returned from the front,
including Crimean Tatars
who had just been
involved in taking Berlin.
They were all accused
of being collaborators with Nazi Germany
and all to a person deported
far away from their home,
such that the Crimean peninsula
became empty of its indigenous population
as of spring of 1944.
Minor note, they were
deported in Studebakers,
American automobiles,
which is just another one
of these interesting historical facts
that are so essential for
how things actually happen,
but which everybody afterwards
doesn't want to remember.
The Soviet Union was able to defend itself
because of American economic aid.
The role that the United States
played in the Second World War,
at least on the European front,
was mostly economic until close to the end
and it was instantiated
in our very relevant
material aid to the Soviet
Union even across the Pacific.
The Americans don't like to remember that
because of the Cold War,
the Soviets don't like to remember it
because of the Cold War
but that's the truth.
And if you think of the NKVD
deporting the Crimean Tatars
in Studebakers, in Jeeps,
it can help you remember
that constellation,
which only a couple of years
later would seem very strange.
So this notion that you
deport an entire people
because they supposedly collaborated
as a people with the Nazis is helpful,
not just so that we understand
the particular failure
of the Crimean Tatars,
to which we're gonna return
because it's a part of
the history of Ukraine,
but also it helps to place
in context the general idea
that I'm going to do something
to you as a collective
because you're Nazis, right,
or because you collaborated with Nazis.
This is a very fruitful idea
in Soviet and then Russian practice
beginning no later than 1943.
So a similar idea is applied
when the Soviets get to Western Ukraine
where they then refer to
Ukrainian Nationalists,
the partisans I spoke about before,
but also self-conscious
Ukrainians in general
as collaborators
and associate them with Nazi rule.
And here, of course, there's a case
thousands of these men and
women had in fact collaborated.
It would be wrong to say
that the entire group had
collaborated, many of them had,
but of course many other people had.
As no one will ever say,
Russians also collaborated.
Right, every national
group in the Soviet Union
to say something which is not,
which is controversial, but shouldn't be,
every national group in the Soviet Union
that was touched by
German power collaborated.
They all did.
And any attempt by one group
in the Soviet Union to say,
"Well, we were innocent and
the other ones were guilty",
wrong.
The statistical evidence
of which we have a fair bit
shows that the only group
which might have collaborated
a little bit more than the
others, not surprisingly,
were the ethnic Germans themselves.
And the only group which perhaps
maybe did a little bit
less than the others
as far as we can tell
were the Belorussians.
But in general, everybody collaborated.
And so in general, the
claim from the Soviet side
that we were innocent but the
other ones were collaborators
is going to be wrong.
But Stalin had power so he
could make this kind of argument
and it was made in Western Ukraine.
The way that the Soviets
approached Western Ukraine
has two parts.
The first is defeat the nationalist
movement, which they do.
The Ukrainian partisan army
or insurgent army, this UPA,
had been formed to fight the Soviets.
It's remembered in Poland,
and it is remembered in Poland
for ethnically cleansing the Poles,
but it was built to fight the Soviet Union
and it did I mean with,
it should be said, with
incredible determination.
They fought on for a very long time
against both Soviet power
and Polish communist power
into the late '40's or
even the early 1950s,
although by that time,
a lot of it was already
controlled by the Soviets.
This was beaten down
with counterinsurgency,
which was just as violent
as the insurgency itself.
A man called Nikita Khrushchev
defined the principle
that we should be more
violent towards them
than they are towards us
because that's the only way to,
that's the only way to defeat them.
That the Soviets use
practices such as, you know,
they would kill,
when they killed a nationalist partisan,
they would bring the body and
drop it in the local village
to see who would come out
because whoever came out were the family
and then the family would be deported
because the principle
was that the families would be deported.
So about 250,000 people were
deported from Western Ukraine.
Probably a larger number
of people were killed
during this counter insurgency.
So one approach to Western Ukraine
was to crush the insurgency,
by killing the partisans and
deporting their family members.
At this time, the Gulag became
disproportionately Ukrainian.
The other approach was to
fulfill the nationalist agenda.
And this is a feature
of post-war communism
in Eastern Europe in general
is that it makes a hard ethnic turn.
So they fulfill the
nationalist agenda, number one,
by giving Ukraine westerly borders.
In 1945, the Soviet Union
basically gets the same borders
from the Americans and the British
that they did from the Nazis in 1939.
Again, a point that no one
really is super comfortable with,
but with a few small exceptions.
Basically, the border of
1945 is the border of 1939,
which means that once again,
Soviet Ukraine is extended
significantly to the west.
Some of this is is from other places,
but most of this is
formally Polish territories.
And this deprived the Ukrainian
Nationalists of an argument
because Ukrainian Nationalists
were all about creating a larger Ukraine.
And the Soviet Union
continues the ethnic cleansing
of local non-Ukrainians.
They basically,
the NKVD basically comes in and picks up
in a more organized way
where the Ukrainian
Nationalists had left off.
About 1.5 million pre-war Polish citizens
will be deported
from what becomes the western
part of Soviet Ukraine.
And 1.5 million is a pretty big number.
Incidentally, of those Polish citizens,
roughly 100,000 were Jewish
survivors of the Holocaust
who were deported westward to Poland
because they were not Ukrainian.
And the reason this,
there are many reasons that
might seem strange to you,
but one of them surely would be
that this is an ethnic deportation.
So it wasn't about citizenship.
The Soviets were saying
if you're an Eastern Slav, basically,
if you're a Belorussian or
a Ukrainian you can stay,
but if you're a Pole or a
Jew, then you have to go,
then you have to go.
Right, so those people were deported.
Meanwhile, simultaneously,
Ukrainians are being deported from Poland
in the opposite direction, right?
So the ethnic cleansing
goes in both sides.
The first major policy of
the Polish Communist regime
is to deport Ukrainians, right?
So they legitimate themselves
on the basis of what had been
a hard right Polish position
before the Second World War.
Right before the Second World War
the idea of deporting all
the remaining Ukrainians
would've been almost
beyond the imagination.
It's the first thing
that the communists do.
And in that way, their polish communism
is ethnic from the beginning.
It will be ethnic in other ways later on.
For example, in 1968, they
will try to deport the Jews.
But the original sin, so to
speak, is 1945, '46, '47.
In 1947, the Ukrainians
who remain in Poland
after this deportation,
most of them are deported inside Poland
in an action which is
remembered as Operation Vistula,
where the idea is to take
Ukrainians and disperse them
around the so-called recovered
territories of Poland,
the lands that Poland got from Germany.
And the idea was to
take them as individuals
so that they couldn't form
Ukrainian communities again.
So that's the way that,
that's the way the Ukrainian question
was handled in communist Poland.
And it was associated
with the attempt of the communist regime
to legitimate itself quite
openly from the beginning.
And the idea that
Ukrainians were the enemy
or one of the main enemies,
the second enemy after the Germans,
was very important to
legitimating Polish communism
all the way to the end.
The Ukrainians were demonized
within Polish communism
all the way through the 1980s.
The conflict between Poles
and Ukrainians was very real,
but it was exploited by the
Polish communist regime.
And this was very convenient, of course,
for the Soviets, right?
Because the last thing
the Soviets would want
would be some kind of Polish Ukrainian
cooperation or understanding.
And as we will see a few
lectures down the line,
when you get to Polish
Ukrainian understanding
about history and many other things,
that is one of the factors
that leads to the end of
the Soviet Union, okay.
So this is a very,
from the Polish point of view,
this is of course a very real history.
In the post '89 period,
both a president and a
prime minister of Poland
have had family members
who were killed in Viluna,
which they may or may not
talk about publicly, right?
This is a fact about Polish
political life, which makes,
I'm just gonna say this,
just gonna note this,
it makes the reception of
the six or seven million
Ukrainian refugees in
2022 much more interesting
because a lot of people when
they look at that, they say,
"Oh, well, the Ukrainians and the Poles,
well I mean surely they just like,
they're friends, they look at
them, they're white people,
they must get along, right?"
From a distance, it can
look like that, right?
But in fact, Ukrainian Polish relations
are incredibly complicated,
as you've probably gathered in this class.
And 1943 is one of many,
and Ukrainians would point to others
on the other side, of course,
one of many very difficult moments
in Ukrainian Polish relations.
So the 2022 thing
is actually much, much more
interesting than it looks.
A lot of Americans looked
at it from our own optic
and didn't see like, oh wow,
like something special is
actually happening here,
which I think it's fair to say there was.
Okay, the underlying move here
though, as you've noticed,
is a move towards,
is a move towards what you could think of
as a quietly emerging
Russian ethnic definition
of the Soviet state
where ethnicity itself has
become much more important.
Soviet Ukraine has been enlarged,
it's been reformed,
it has a slightly different,
has a different kind of
population with fewer Poles,
and of course, far fewer Jews
who have been murdered in the Holocaust.
But underneath that,
there's a notion that it's
ethnicity that matters
and that it's the Russian ethnicity
which is the most important.
And to make this case,
which is the last thing
we're gonna talk about,
I'm gonna start with
something that Stalin said
at the end of the war, two
weeks after the end of the war,
24 May, 1945.
And this is when Stalin
makes his famous toast
to the great Russian nation,
which I'm gonna read
to you in its entirety
because it's important.
Okay, "Comrades,
permit me to propose one more last toast.
I should like to propose a toast
to the health of our Soviet people,
and in the first place,
the Russian people.
I drink in the first place
to the health of the Russian people
because it is the most outstanding
nation of all the nations
forming the Soviet Union.
I propose a toast to the
health of the Russian people
because it has won in this
war universal recognition
as the leading force of the Soviet Union
among all the peoples of our country.
I propose a toast to the
health of the Russian people,
not only because it is leading people,
but because it possesses a clear mind,
a staunch character and patience.
Our government made not a few errors.
We experienced at moments
of desperate situation
in 1941, 1942, when our
army was retreating,
abandoning our own villages and
towns, et cetera, et cetera.
A different people could
have said to the government,
you have failed to justify expectations.
Go away, we shall install
another government,
which will conclude peace with Germany
and ensure us a quiet life.
The Russian people, however,
did not take this path
because it trusted the correctness
of the policy of its government
and it made sacrifices to
ensure the route of Germany.
The confidence of the Russian people
in the Soviet government proved
to be that decisive force
which ensured the historic victory
over the enemy of humanity, over fascism.
Thanks to it, the Russian
people for this confidence.
To the health of the Russian people."
Now there's something ironic
about a toast to fascism
where you talk about how your nation
is better than everybody else's.
Yes?
- [Student] Why is he saying this?
He's Georgian, right?
- Yeah, yeah, he's Georgian,
that's right, he's Georgian.
But you don't,
you know, you don't have
to belong to a nation
to use or even believe in an ethnic idea.
But see, I want you to note
the difficulties in all this.
Russia was great,
and I'm now only slightly paraphrasing
because it was less
touched by German power
than Belarus and Ukraine.
You see?
The Russians are steadfast and patient,
that's Stalin's spin,
because they're not occupied.
Of course, the German war
did kill many Russians.
The most atrocious example is the hunger,
the terror siege, the
hunger siege of Leningrad
in which more than a
million people are killed.
The scale of Russian death
is horrible from a Western
point of view, it's terrifying.
But it's much less proportionately
than the scale of death in
Belarus and Ukraine, much less,
even, not just relatively,
but with respect to Ukraine, absolutely.
It's fewer people, fewer
civilians killed than Russians.
And the reason why,
you know, the reason why the Soviet Union
won the Second World War,
isn't that just that Russians
came running to the rescue.
You know, on the contrary,
more Ukrainian soldiers die
fighting the Germans in the Red Army
than Americans, British
and French put together.
And when the Red Army is
pushing back through Ukraine
and taking horrible losses, which it does,
of all of its peoples,
including the Russians for sure,
but it's picking up its
reserves from Ukraine
as it's then moving into
Poland and towards Berlin.
So what happens is
ironically here by 1945,
is that you have this capacity
to decide which nation is great,
which nation is greater
than the other nation.
And you have implicitly
also the power to decide
who's the collaborator and who is not.
And that's going to be the
legacy of the Second World War,
a major legacy of the Second World War
for Soviet and Russian
power for decades onwards.
And it's based on what I
wouldn't hesitate to call
a flat out totalitarian lie,
because you see what's happened by 1945.
The man who after Hitler is
most personally responsible
for beginning the Second World War,
and indeed, the man who with Hitler
began the second world
war as an ally in 1939,
now has the authority to define
who are the real collaborators, right?
And no one is ever supposed
to think about that.
And indeed, in Russia today,
there's a law which forbids you
from mentioning anything along those lines
in any kind of media, right?
But this power to have
been the ally of Hitler
and then to tell you who
the ally of Hitler is
is very important for Soviet practice
and it also helps a great deal now.
If you're trying to understand
the Russian rhetoric
about Nazis and de-Nazification
and fascism and so on,
it helps a lot to know
that the Nazis are who
we say they are, right?
The Nazis are who we say they
are and that's what it means,
the collaborators are who we say they are.
So as the Cold War begins,
there's a new cultural focus on Ukraine,
which is defined by a
fellow called Zhdanov
in a larger cultural turn.
And the attitude about Ukraine
is something like this,
that there are two camps in the world,
and the camps are,
they call them the democracies.
Right, Zhdanov when he says
the democracies, he means us,
he means he means the
Soviet Union and its allies,
and then there are the
fascists, the capitalists.
And in these two camps,
what's interesting about these camps,
there's not really any
longer a vision of progress.
And let me pause on that
because it's really, really important.
After the Second World War,
the Soviet notion of legitimacy
is gonna be based much less on economics
and much more on culture.
And the reason for this
is that the Stalinist
transformation of the Soviet economy
has essentially been completed.
Awkwardly, the Stalinist transformation
of the Soviet economy did
not actually bring socialism
in any sense.
I mean we can call it
socialism if you want,
we can call it state socialism,
we can call it whatever,
but it's not socialism in
the sense understood by Marx.
We do not have harmony,
we do not have equality.
We don't have any of the things
which any of the 19th century idealists,
or Marx in is more sentimental
moments, described.
None of that prevails in the Soviet Union.
But the Stalinist transformation is over.
Collectivization has happened.
The factories have been built,
the mines have been dug.
You can dig some more,
you can build some more,
but essentially the
transformation has happened
and it hasn't brought the expected result.
Instead, there's been a terrifying war,
which the Soviet Union just barely won
with the help of the Americans,
which has to be now
forgotten very quickly.
But this fundamentally,
the fact that the Soviet
transformation is over,
and you have this shift
from economics to culture,
means that the whole nature
of the way the Soviets are
gonna define themselves
against the West is now
a little bit different.
It has much more to do with a
notion of cultural innocence.
So when Zhdanov says there are two camps,
he means we are the good guys
and the capitalists are the bad guys.
The capitalists who were
our allies a moment ago
now turn out to be fascists.
And by the way, the dance
that the Americans do
is almost as extraordinary, right?
I mean Stalin's on the cover
of Life Magazine in 1943
and there's a whole special
issue which I have in my office,
come to office hours, it'd
be great to see you guys,
but there's a whole special issue
about how wonderful the
great Russian people are
and how they're the leader
of all the peoples of the Soviet Union
and how the great Russian
people are just like America.
It's really interesting
if you're in American studies
because it's just like America,
like the Russians are just
like the white people,
like they're in charge.
And look, there's some
pictures of people of color
and they're kind of subordinate,
but they like being ruled
by these white people,
the Russians, who are just
like the American white people.
But the point is
that the Americans also
had to make this turn
where they went from being
the allies of the Soviet Union
who were all Democrats in
the sense of small D right,
Hollywood was in on this.
There were great movies
about how the Soviets
were the greatest democracy in the world.
We had this shift from nought to Cold War
in just a few years.
Okay, but the way the
Soviets do it is they say,
this is all, you know, this is
fundamentally about fascism.
the fascists or who we say they are,
but here's the important point.
The important point is
that this then becomes
about cultural innocence.
And the lodestone of what's
special about the Soviet Union
is no longer the economic transformation.
That's happened, it turned
out to be a bit of a dud,
can't really say so.
The lodestone of what's
special about the Soviet Union
is now much more Russian culture.
And Zhdanov,
the same fellow who gives us
this whole two camps idea,
is also responsible for a cultural policy
in which the idea is that Russian culture
is basically good culture
so long as it's not contaminated
by outside influences.
And the Russian writers and
poets who are then persecuted
are persecuted because they've
allowed alien influences,
cosmopolitan influences
into Russian literature.
And on this account of
the way the world works,
naturally, Ukrainian culture
is going to be downgraded
because Ukrainian culture
is closer to the west,
it's been contaminated
most recently by German occupation, right?
And so this becomes another
way that Russia is elevated
as against Ukraine.
And I just want to just
give you one little thought
about what this four ordains.
We're not there yet.
Okay, Stalin's still in power,
it's now the early 1950s, let's say,
and we're not there yet,
but we're now going to be
reach into the question of,
well, if this is all about cultures
and Russian culture
is the one that's central
and pure and important
and Ukraine is kind of
a little bit defiled
and on the outside, what is Ukraine?
Khrushchev has an answer to that.
Khrushchev's answer,
and we'll talk about this next time,
is Ukraine is a slightly
less important culture,
which always wanted to join Russia.
So it exists but the
point of its existence
was to join Russia, right?
Which is an elegant answer
and is taken up by many people
and it becomes very popular.
And then Brezhnev will
have another answer,
which is that now that
Ukraine has joined Russia
de facto and forever,
culture, it's going to become something
which is much less important,
culture is just going to become something
that you have at home.
The Ukrainian language will be something
that maybe you have at
home or on the countryside,
but the Soviet Union is gonna be run
as a kind of very efficient technical
administrative apparatus
in which Russian is going
to be the neutral language
that everyone's going to use
and everyone's going to know.
So Khrushchev and Brezhnev
have different answers
about what Ukraine is going
to be within the Soviet Union,
we'll spend more time on them.
But at the base is this is
this thing which happens
during the second world
war, which is that Ukraine,
precisely because Ukraine
is under occupation
and Ukrainians suffer more,
has to be presented as
contaminated and dangerous,
and precisely because the
economic transformation is over
and there's a shift now towards culture,
there's the potential for
a shift towards nostalgia,
where the Soviet Union
is gonna become with time
not just more about culture and economics,
but more about the past
than about the present
or the future, right?
By the time we get to Brezhnev,
the cult of the Second World War
will have replaced the revolution
as the central focus of the
Soviet Union as a whole.
And if everything's about the past
and if everything's about nostalgia,
then you're setting
yourself up for actually,
you know, a very right
wing view of the world.
And then the process that you get
when the Soviet Union falls
apart and you get to today
becomes less mysterious.
Okay, trying to do a lot today.
Hope it came through.
Thank you very much.
(gentle music)